this just feels a little extreme Risa
breaking the law on everything I don't
want to go to jail I'm not ready to be a
lesbian yet Maria did you even remember
to apply for college I know things can
get hard for you yeah they do
they're called dicks Kelly I cannot
believe these be friends with those
girls
they're so dusty looking I want to throw
the party in for friendship sighing then
you know I want to be at that funeral
idiots you want to [ __ ] these kids up
tonight Oh God we're just trying figure
out where the party is tonight meets who
I asked them dude you just called me a
boner this party could be anywhere and
nowhere at the same time why don't we
just let these kids have their moment
this is my moment it is the last day of
school you were not an even sale
inappropriate language offensive
clothing the verdict for both of us
detention why don't you please take that
bow no I will not our rules are for
texture and kill bent over the window
but they're painted shut
rumor has it the last counselor left to
her death I love you guys so much you're
my best friends there's only one way to
do this
that's the pace in which they're gonna
[ __ ] you in the air in prison right
Jesus [ __ ] take a lot brother [ __ ] [ __ ]
dip in your but it never stops
you